hello folks welcome to rational science
and we have a busy day today so I'm
going to get right to it I'm going to
skip the extinction segment because
we've got quite a bit on our plate today
so I'm gonna be dealing with some of the
subjects we've been talking about lately
in fact
um we've been talking about space
uh
before you know a couple weeks ago uh
how the establishment sees space they
think of it as a physical object as a
thing
and a uh that's how they're going to be
doing uh gravity you know bending of
space time they've been to space and
time a lot of dissonance disagree with
that and today we're going to be talking
about them and comparing them comparing
the dissidents Against The Establishment
so uh what are the uh these folks
propose instead well we talked about
that a couple for the last couple weeks
uh they talked to or they propose
counter space ether field and of course
they also talk about space okay and they
think that uh some of them at least
think that space is a thing as well okay
so uh that's a subject matter and then
from there we're gonna be moving into
what some of these people think
um
yeah what they propose for the universe
How the Universe really works okay okay
um I hope everybody can hear me all
right okay let me know otherwise okay
the second year okay
okay so
um if you want to know what uh what an
object is in physics the way you present
it for the purposes of physics you point
to it okay so if you want to know what a
rock is you point to it say rock
okay very simple kindergarten stuff
uh you want to know what a house is you
uh point to it
and you say house
see how simple it is
very simple and if you want to know what
a uh
what a table is well you point and you
say table
okay very simple straightforward
hopefully there are no questions you
know that's the way we present objects
in physics okay so any object that you
want to present and you say look this is
going to be the actor in my movie that's
going to be the actor in my theory right
you point to him at the beginning
starting so that people can follow your
presentation and they know what you're
going to be talking about they know what
it is that is moving okay you point and
name
okay so um if you want to explain uh
some of these words that I just
mentioned you know like counter space uh
ether field Etc you want to explain that
to a or or you want to introduce them
not explain them but introduce them to a
uh
an ET for example a Klingon well again
you've got a point and name okay so uh
here it is uh you know you say uh what
is counter space Sam you know and uh
please point to it it right it's got to
be an it only objects can be it's so you
point and you say okay that's counter
space
straightforward real easy right
and uh if you want to introduce the uh
ether if I can get it
give me a second here I think on the
other side
where is it now
give me a second here
we introduced The Ether well you have to
point and say ether
that's the way you do it okay
and uh you do that for for absolutely
everything okay
um
give me a second here we've got some of
these that are uh there you go okay
there's The Ether okay anyways you uh
point and say ether and there you have
to point to it so that people no you
point with your inner finger and say
either and so everybody knows what
you're going to talk about you they know
what the
object is that you're going to be moving
in your theory okay so you point a name
very simple very kindergarten stuff okay
okay so um you know I asked the people
to go in there and tell me what the
ether is but not to tell me but to
illustrate it to go on the internet and
find a place where they show what the
ether is or you know upload your own
picture I don't care you know uh just
upload a picture and say look that's the
ether
and so we know what you're what what you
have going through your mind when you
say the word ether or the word counter
space or the word field or whichever
right and uh these are the images that
you will see you know if you put ether
out there okay and uh it's very simple
you know uh you say okay what is The
Ether and these are the images you get
in Google Images and what you see is
what people think of as The Ether and
you can see they're all thinking of
different things they all illustrate
different things okay just in case uh I
went in there and looked for The
luminiferous Ether which is the one that
concerns science and this is what you
get okay you get uh all these pictures
and what you see is that The Ether are a
bunch of lines in all these lines that
go across the Earth and the Sun and all
this stuff uh here's a better picture
and when you take everything out like
Suns stars planets when you remove
everything this is what what's left of
the ether okay there it is that's what
the ether looks like according to all
these sites That's The luminiferous
Ether okay
very clear
and the question is what it what is it
that we're staring at what what is that
what are you looking at you're looking
at a bunch of arrows there a dotted
lined arrows uh is that what the ether
is a bunch of dots with uh arrows at the
end of them
you know this is what you get this is
the illustration you get for The Ether
and so if this is not the ether what is
The Ether because there you see an
illustration of The Ether okay and you
don't have to take my word for it you
can go into uh do a Google
um uh images of The luminiferous Ether
and that's what you'll get
and so when I ask people to illustrate
The Ether they say oh Bill you're you're
playing word games this is a
straightforward question I mean there
shouldn't be any any way you know you
shouldn't put your tail between your
legs and run away you should say look
this is The Ether build this is what I'm
talking about very straightforward
okay it's very easy in fact that's what
what all these dissidents
you know uh they have the problem they
have with the establishment
is the fact that they don't like the
officially the word time but in general
the word space time
you know uh establishment says look uh
gravity is the warpage of space-time
it's a bending of space-time that's what
yes geometry
and these people say what do you mean
space time what is space-time
and again they're thinking of you know
show me what space time is you know and
what you see out there what they'll put
out there is something like this okay
they Point uh to a little fishnet and
they say look the sun Works ways down
the canvas creates a depression and
because of that depression the Earth
rolls around this depression has no way
of getting out of this
um of this depression of this
roulette-like mechanism okay so the
earth goes around the sun because it's
uh the sun is weighing down a hole okay
depression and uh the earth goes around
and all dissidents saying this is
nonsense this is what is this nonsense
and why because again that what they
have in the back of their mind is uh is
that they um they can't understand the
object that is being presented sometimes
they present it as a 3D object here you
see the 3D version of space now which is
even bigger bunk because they say look
you know uh it's misrepresented into
two-dimensional world you have to
represent it in the 3D World okay there
you have more or less a 3D World okay
what is this nonsense they're saying
that all these um this canvas instead of
uh the sun weighing it downwards uh the
the sun pulls it towards its Center and
so does the Earth and so the Earth
doesn't fly away from the sun because
the sun the sun is pulling the canvas
towards its Center and the Earth is
pulling the uh the uh canvas towards its
Center well the first thing I need to
mention is that Einstein would laugh at
all these people saying that there are a
bunch of and I'll be kind there are a
bunch of idiots
because that's not what a relativity
says at all but that's a side from the
you know beside the point the issue here
is that if the sun pulls whatever canvas
that is whatever that thing is towards
the center and the Earth towards the
center well then we have to identify
those lines what are those lines you
know what what are we talking about
and what you're staring at are number
lines that's what those lines are number
lines okay they're not length with a
knight they're not even that they're not
Dimensions they're not coordinates they
are numbered lines that's what a
mathematician deals with so we're
pulling number lines towards the center
of the earth and the center of the Sun
and so they say look it's not that the
Earth or the Sun weighs the 2D canvas
downwards it's uh it's pulling the 3D
canvas inwards towards the center
towards the singularity
and don't ever find the singularity
because they say that the laws of
physics break down there
so so uh you know you're not governed by
the laws of physics anymore once you
fall into the singularity so we have
nonsense and bigger nonsense that's all
we have and so all the dissonance
rightfully
uh you know point that out and say look
you know uh it's what you're saying is
nonsense you're saying that there's a
bending of War of space time your
warping time you know what is this
that's not a mechanism that's nonsense
and they're totally right you know this
is poppycock
but uh why because nobody can deal with
the object of space-time as an object
that's the issue that's the underlying
issue basically when they say oh it's
four dimensional and you cannot even
imagine it that makes it even worse
because they're they're just
um sidestepping the issue they're just
saying no you can't imagine it so don't
try but we've proven it
okay you're proven it great
okay so this is uh this is the starting
point and uh so people ask questions and
here's uh one fellow who brought up an
issue and uh second guy who uh also
doubled up on that and they said the
following the first guy said these there
is electricity it's uh magnetism it's
gravity it's a fluid
it's a fluid okay whatever a fluid is
but that's a fluid okay ethers is
substance it's a substance it's a fluid
okay and it's uh it's a very fizzy it's
a it's very physical it's a thing okay
and the other fella he said no no you're
you're wrong and supposedly these two
fellows are experts in ether because
they I guess they both proposed The
Ether okay and so they've done some
research on each one on their own they
reached completely different conclusions
of what the ether is that's my point
here okay and this fellow says either
it's non-spatial so can it be a fluid
ether has no shape okay so it's not
physical it's not a thing because it has
no shape right it's pure potential it's
a promise
yeah that's what it is inertial
non-spatial whatever that is
anti-spatial counterspatial
so we have a counter spatial versus uh
fluid that's what it is whatever those
two poor guys are talking about okay and
uh yeah I mean it's very hard to follow
what these people are saying and so um
so here um
so I I challenge the first guy in fact
let me put it over here so that uh we
can see it better uh the fella who said
it's a fluid I'm saying okay what is a
fluid well fluid if you look it up it
says a liquid gas or other wet material
okay so uh yeah a fluid is a thing it's
material and they are substances okay so
so far this guy's on the right track but
what are what is a fluid well all
substances all material are made up of
atoms and molecules and uh you know and
and so the question is whether the ether
is made up of molecules atoms and all
this stuff
and he's got to answer that question I'm
not going to answer a form I think he's
going to say no okay but uh he's uh the
ball's in his court not in mind he's got
to tell me if he's going to say that
it's a fluid
then he's saying it's made out of atoms
and or and or molecules and if he says
no to that then it can't be a fluid
because that's what a fluid is
okay and so otherwise he's got to define
the word fluid in such a way that he can
uh you know encompasses uh The Ether but
the issue is that if ether is a fluid he
still hasn't pointed to it he just it's
a fluid it's like saying uh you know
table is is furniture and so is chair
well Furniture is a category like liquid
is a category like solids and gases
those are categories
you haven't told me anything you haven't
pointed to it you know we say uh chair
you know that's Furniture uh couch
Furniture okay but by saying that it's
Furniture you haven't told me what a
chair is you got a point to chair
okay and that's different than same
Furniture very generic name category and
to say it's a fluid you know well we
have oil we have water we have so many
fluids even Mercury flows sometimes you
know it's hot enough
so uh no you can't say it's just a fluid
you haven't told us anything you have
the point and name
okay that ether that's very simple stuff
that I'm I'm asking you to do I'm not
asking you anything out of the ordinary
here okay
okay so he comes back and he says the
following he says you're asking me what
the ether is again yeah I'm asking you
what is The Ether point to it it says
and I already told you multiple times no
no I don't want you to tell me I want
you to point a name I want you to
identify an a physical object I want you
to put a shape there in front of us and
say That's The Ether
how how difficult can that be okay and
then he says on the other hand you
haven't told us what your ropes are
I've told you what I wrote my ropes are
yes I have look this is what a rope is
I'm sorry you've never seen one in your
life but uh this is what a rope looks
like that's what a rope is the word rope
anywhere in the universe
it looks something like this maybe it's
this is a two strand room you can find a
freestand strand rope out there in fact
um here it is let me show you okay
I'm gonna put over here okay that's what
a rope is looks like uh the top one is a
two-strand rope the lower one has a
three strand but that's more or less
what a rope looks like now if you go to
the land of the in uh Klingons they they
don't call it rope they call it e-port
they use it exactly in Reverse okay no
problem so they call it e-port but ipor
over there and rope over here are the
same thing you point to an object you
can call it X for All We Care
and I'm showing you what it is it's uh
right up there at the bottom in Black in
a black uh rectangle there
uh rub is a two strand rope when the
atoms expand and contract you know they
torqued a rope and that's what we call
light
I don't know what part you're missing
what part uh you can't understand this
is kindergarten stuff so I'm not sure
why it's over your head okay and
um
and we also go a little beyond the Call
of Duty and we also show you know how
it's uh
um how it relates to the uh wave okay
let me remove this for a second here
okay you can see why
um
we put the Rope the Rope matches exactly
what the wave has always been you know
they have this so-called wave made of
two Fields one is the called the
electrode the other one the magnetic and
as we call them threads we're saying
that they're physical objects because
see the wave electromagnetic wave it's
made out of vectors and these people
don't understand it they think they're
looking at an object and no it's not
what you have is all these engine arrows
that are pointing in different
directions and what you're staring at is
magnitude and directions what you're
staring at is a mathematical concept not
a physical object so when they say it's
an electric field in a magnetic field
they're talking about Concepts they're
not what is a field a bunch of numbers
that's all a field is and so uh and
besides it travels one way because it
it's allegedly emitted by an atom okay
when it quantum jumps so what you have
there is a concept first of all they're
talking about numbers you're talking
about quantities and uh it also goes one
way which is irrational because Numbers
Never travel okay but this is what
you're staring at you're you're staring
at a picture of traveling numbers
vectors okay and
um and what we're saying no what what
these people have always mistaken life
for is this wave and it's not a wave
it's a rope a rope that uh has the same
shape okay it's a two-strand rope and
we're just to keep with convention we
call it the electric thread and the
Magnetic thread and yes uh we can
explain at least why light travels at a
constant speed okay why because you have
the wave equation there where C is the
velocity of your light 300 000
kilometers per second and it's equal to
frequency times wavelength if you
increase the frequency the wavelength
Goes Down And if you increase the
wavelength the frequency goes down and
there you see why we have an explanation
for that we're saying that if you take
any rope any length of rope okay you
torque it more and more and more right
you have a one meter length of rope and
you torque it more and more and more
well you're going to get shorter length
and you're going to get more links and
that's why C is a consonant why light
always travels at the same speed okay
because it doesn't travel at all it's
just what we're looking at is the number
of uh humps you know that we get uh in a
given length of rope that's all it is
okay so uh we do have an explanation for
why the Rope is the good Model A Perfect
model for what they've always been uh
calling a wave a transverse wave and as
you can see you know the Rope since it
torques right the signal travels both
ways simultaneously
it's the only object that can do that
and it's the only object that can
imitate the wave equation it's got a lot
of uh things it's in its favor okay okay
so um let me get this photo back here uh
and so he says uh on the other hand you
haven't told us what your ropes are yeah
I have told you and here you see it
here's the construction okay that's why
also it's related to the atoms okay you
can see uh how an atom is uh made and
it's made of the same thread that makes
up the Rope so we have rope atom rope
Madame rope Adam forever right as far as
you want to go and what you see is how
it's made you know one thread goes
around and encapsulates the one the
thread that goes through the center of
the atom and comes out the other end so
an atom is a perfectly round sphere it
is a sphere it's a membrane the electron
is a membrane not a little particle and
the membrane encapsulates a star which
is the proton the proton is a star there
you see it okay and you can see how uh
the they stop at the electron shell
which is the the red one there let me
see it one let's look at it one more
time you see the electron shell which is
the red one and it's there is a 2d
version of it okay but you'll see now
the 3D version there okay and what it is
is you know one thread goes around the
other one goes through and it builds
this thing we call an atom it's like a
knot in uh in the uh
a world of matter okay okay so we do
have a consistent uh
picture of of it all we have two atoms
which are made of the same threads as
the rope that interconnects them the
atoms expand and contract and when they
do so they torque the rope and light
travels in both directions which is a
signal that we can call it propagates
what really is happening is you know the
Rope is really truly in place but we can
say it propagates through the rope and
you can see that you can twist any rope
and you can see the signal is at the
other end instantaneously practically
instantaneously in fact uh you can do
the trick I've done it several times
where you put two
um you you get a rope very tight rope
right you put two
clothespins at each end and you just
move one clothespin you'll see the other
one move instantaneously you had better
okay and the tighter that you make the
Rope the faster you'll get that and
that's our model for uh for light what
we're saying is light is a very very
thin
extremely thin and invisibly invisibly
thin rope made of two strands a braided
uh
helical right and the atoms expand and
contract when doing so they open and
close in other words the Rope
at the the two threads that merge into
it and by doing so it trucks the rope
and glycos in both directions
uh uh the links on the Rope the shorter
they are you have high frequency meaning
many links and the links are shorter and
if the links are longer then you're
going to have fewer links very simple
stuff baby stuff kindergarten stuff okay
they never figured it out why because
they've been dealing with math and with
waves and with particles that's why they
never figured it out so we're brushing
all that aside throwing it all in the
trash can and you ask heap of History
the only side in the on the planet here
right we're getting rid of all that
we're saying look what they've been
mistaking all these years is a rope uh
and for a wave okay they thought it was
a wave all these years okay
um and this fellow says yeah nothing
mystical uh or metaphysical entirely
irrational no your yours is not rational
until you can take a p give us a picture
then you cannot even start your
presentation because we don't know what
you're talking about when you say ether
okay
and he says he gave up he says he says
I'm not discussing either with you
anymore you're only obsessed with
semantics yeah they dismiss it as
semantics uh because
um uh they can't answer the question
and the question is very simple point to
it that's the question
see how easy it is just you know here
I'm pointing at at the Rope
I'm showing you a rope I'm saying what
it is so don't say that I'm not
presenting the Rope I am presenting a
rope okay
okay and uh we're you know the Rope is
made of really a single thread that's in
the universe we're saying that that's
all there is this is all all matter is
made out of that single thread it's a
closed loop thread and this thread
um just twines around itself and creates
everything every bit of matter in the
universe so every bit of matter in the
universe is physically physically
interconnected why because we're all one
thread you're connected to me I'm
connected to the other guy every atom is
connected to all others through a pair
of twine threads and it's a single
thread in the universe if we could
untangle every atom every rope in the
universe we would end up with what you
see there you know like a rubber band uh
you know this is the universe right
there folks
okay uh where is it
okay that's it that's that's the whole
that's the whole universe that's all the
matter sorry all the matter in the
universe then you have space which is
the counterpart and with a space nothing
but it's nothing it's that which has no
shape so we have a definition that we
can use consistently that which has no
shape And we have that which has shape
and there you have that which essay over
with the background of that which
doesn't have shape very simple matter
made of a single thread and what you
have as a background is nothing
space that which has no shape okay easy
okay and uh we can have two universes
okay maybe there are two threads in the
universe or
in space okay and I hate to use the word
in space because space is not a
container but what we're saying is that
there are two threads just twirling uh
in this black stuff that serves as a
backdrop okay now what does that mean
that means that you know maybe there's a
parallel universe okay out there maybe
there's a yet another Universe which uh
none of its atoms are connected to our
universe so these are two different
universes why because none of the atoms
are connected to each other all the
atoms in one thread are connected
amongst themselves and all the atoms of
the other threat are connected between
themselves but none of them are
connected to ours so you can have a
parallel universe under the Rope model
uh speculation we don't care about that
really it's just uh interesting to you
know to
shoot the bull around at the water
cooler and nothing more but all I'm
saying is that our universe just a
single thread that connects every atom
through uh two twine threads that are
made of that same thread okay period
that's very easy really and um
kindergarten stuff you don't need any
math to understand it hopefully because
physics is not about math message is not
descriptions quantitative descriptions
which is all that math is physic is
about explaining how this universe works
and that's our starting point I'm
showing you the hypothesis the
assumptions we have to make and from
there we're going to explain you know
how light works how gravity works and
all this other good stuff that's how it
begins but that's our starting point
which you just said there so yeah don't
tell me that I'm not presenting I'm
presenting the Rope I'm pointing to it
here I'm pointing it to one more time if
you don't believe me that this is a rope
go to your hardware store ask for a
two-strand robe and they're going to
give you something similar to this this
it might say how how much do you want of
it
but they'll give you something in your
hand that you can take home with you
now go to the same hardware store and
say could you give me a pound of ether
what will they give you give me in some
either
so uh the guy says okay let me see if
it's in the catalog
so yeah you can ask her ether because
nobody has any idea what the ether is as
you can see there okay
so uh follow continues as point to me
your ropes okay I point it to my rope
there it is okay uh here it is okay I'm
pointing to my rope okay so there it is
okay so please don't tell me I can't put
tomorrow
I never said The Ether was an object
okay so if it's not an object what is it
it's a concept I mean there's only
objects and Concepts there's nothing
else there's no third category of words
every word in the dictionary it either
designates something that has shape
or that which doesn't
okay so all those things that all those
words that designate that which doesn't
have shape those are all Concepts
see how simple it is so if you say
conscience or you can't point to
conscience
mind I can't point to mind thought I
can't point to thought why because these
are Concepts
but you say tree I can put into a tree I
can point to a dog I can put to a cat
okay so you can point to things but you
can't point to Concepts every word in
the dictionary falls under one of those
two categories either it has shape and
it's an object or it don't have shape
and it's a concept
that's the rule of thumb very simple
okay you can go ahead and look at the
dictionary and see if you can separate
all the words between concept and object
okay so yeah the question is if ether
does not have shape it doesn't have uh
it's not an object then its constant if
it's a concept you can't say you're
going to move a concept around
you can't vibrate the concept like you
vibrate a field you know a field is a
concept how do you vibrate a region of
numbers what do you do you know how do
you excite them they say that excited
field or whatever vibrating teal uh
field or an oscillating field or
whatever you know you can't have that
because it's a concept it's a bunch of
numbers that's what a field is that's
what the word field designates that's
what that's how it's defined officially
so you can't say you're going to vibrate
a bunch of numbers
which is what you're saying when you say
you vibrate a field okay so people don't
understand that they say they first
Define it as a bunch of numbers in a
region and then they don't use that at
all they say okay let's move the field
and the field pushes the charge and you
know they start talking a bunch of
nonsense treating the word field as a
physical object when they just finish
defining it there's a bunch of numbers
they did that see there they've got a
contradiction that they don't never
resolve
okay so this is the issue and so he says
uh of course it has no shame well it has
no shape it's not an object it's not a
thing but see he uses the word substance
he says it's a physical substance
nonetheless
oh my God we have to start very simple
with some of these people anyways
um because does air have shape does
water have shade yes they do and he says
no they don't
water doesn't have shape air doesn't
have shape he said the shape is defined
by a container
absolutely not you've got this wrong bud
and a lot of people make the same
mistake they say water doesn't have
shape air doesn't have shade let's let's
make it sure that you understand
kindergarten physics I'm talking about
Kinder Garden physics you know that's
before first grade okay before hopefully
before high school or college
anything made of atoms had better have
shape because Adam have shape and if an
atom has saved and builds molecules
which have shape and molecules build
gases and liquids and solids
right then they all have shape anything
made out of atoms had better have shape
and so he says uh he doesn't believe air
has shape or that water has shape and
I've already shown him he doesn't
apparently he's not watching I don't
know or listening I I guess he's got a
mental block or something here it is one
more time the astronaut releases a blob
of water of uh of some liquid some fluid
what call it a fluid how's that you mean
this is a fluid from his spaceship
there's no container because that thing
is floating in wet in space meaning in
nothing it has no container
and the question is does that blob have
shape
and hopefully the answer is yes it has
shape and you may say well what is the
shape of that's not the question the
question is
does it have shape not what is the shape
of okay of course when you see a blob
you say well that's an irregular shape
uh you know undescribable shape you know
we don't care about that we're saying
does it have shape and the answer is yes
hopefully it has shape if you have eyes
you would say it has shape now maybe
that one's too neat a shape maybe it
looks more like like this one here
what if it looks like that
okay uh does that have shape well
hopefully it does I mean what you're
staring at is is a shape and if that's
what it looks like in shape when the
astronaut releases The Blob of whatever
of gas or of uh some liquid well then
that has shape it's a yes or no type of
question does it have shape or not the
answer is yes it does have shape
so um so again uh these people have it
all wrong they they they don't know the
basics they they don't know those simple
things like that water has shape air has
shape the air around the earth does it
have shape yes it looks like a shell I
mean if you had the eyes of God you
would see a shell which it gets thinner
and thinner as as you go outwards if you
take the Earth away if you could do that
right if you eliminate the Earth you
would see a shell of molecules covering
the Earth what is the shape of air well
around the earth it looks like a shell
looks like an eggshell it just gets
thinner as as you go up further outwards
hopefully air has shape hopefully Fair
air is an object and people will say
well object that sounds so bad in my ear
that's because you're thinking of
ordinary speech we can't use the words
the definitions the Notions of ordinary
speech and bring them into science
that's why we have to Define all these
words for the purposes of physics of
science because people confuse ordinary
speech with scientific language and when
they want to bring those things in we
say look you're going to have to justify
every definition and they don't like
that they say oh you're doing word salad
you're doing semantics Bill you're doing
ontology or who knows what philosophy
so yeah we have to Define these things
and uh
so can you point me to air yeah we can
point to air it's just color coded and I
can point it out to you air is just a
bunch of molecules a bunch of atoms
yes fuzzy air but we can't see it but if
we could color code it if it had color
you could do it with some other gas that
has color and you release it in outer
space without a container no container
right you would see a blob
that blob hopefully has shape otherwise
you need to see an ophthalmologists
okay very simple very straightforward
okay uh so but what's the issue we got
to start with uh kindergarten physics
for All These Guys these people never
went through kindergarten and they want
to do college stuff they say look I
don't want to do semantics I don't want
to do word salad or Wizardry all that
stuff you do Bill I just want to do
physics
well I'm sorry to tell you physics is
150 percent word solid
okay you got to get you got to lay the
foundations and one of the problems we
have is that nobody's defined the
discipline nobody has a definition of
what physics is nobody has a definition
what uh science is or what philosophy is
go to the Stanford encyclopedia
philosophy number one probably
a dictionary or encyclopedia philosophy
on the planet
very well set up very well argued Etc
everywhere right and look up the word
philosophy
and you won't find it
so here you have the Stanford
encyclopedia philosophy and they and the
word they never defined is the word
philosophy so we don't know what the
what the Stanford encyclopedia
philosophy is about because they don't
Define the word that defines their uh
discipline so we don't know what
philosophy is and uh physics is in the
same boat what is fizzy well they say
blah blah blah it's the study of energy
what do you mean the study of energy
what is energy they say oh we don't know
but we study it
uh they don't know what energy they
can't find it they say there's a million
types of energy potential energy and who
knows what kind of energy and they say
we don't know what energy is but we're
studying it that's what we study and
yeah anytime they begin any discipline
by saying the study of
you know it's a person who
wrote that definition
you know what is paleontology the study
of what is biology the study of like
there are no biologists on Earth
why because you ask about what do you
what do you do I'm a biologist oh you're
a biologist uh so what is a biologist
well we study life
you studied life what is life oh we
don't know we don't have a definition
but that's what we study
and so you know my kid uh when he was in
kindergarten he studied blocks and he
would put one block on top of the other
he studied blocks
so was he a scientist because he studied
blocks
the does a person who studies I don't
know math or history and fails the test
the fact that they uh you know didn't
get any question right the fact that
they studied does that make him a
historian a physicist or whatever
no so any person who defines a
discipline is the study of doesn't have
no squat
you don't Define any discipline like
that and since this is the problem that
he said the study of no science is not
the study of nothing
science is explanations rational
explanations that's what science is if
you have an irrational explanation it
doesn't belong in science and for that
you have to Define what an explanation
is and what rational means and I've gone
through that in the past and I won't
touch that today but yeah it has to be
rational explanation it's a if it's an
irrational explanation like everything
that comes out of mathematical physics
in fact everything every single thing
100 that comes out of mathematical
physics is irrational none of it has
anything to do with physics or with
science okay warping time that that's an
explanation that's a ratio explanation
particle of two places at once no no
that belongs in science period we're
done I mean they can say whatever they
want at the Asylum over there
mathematical Asylum uh they don't fool
people who have a little bit of uh more
uh what do you call it Street smartness
okay uh okay so let's take these fellows
to uh kindergarten physics they have to
go through kindergarten physics because
they they've never taken kindergarten
they skipped kindergarten they want to
jump directly to college
okay so here let's go with kindergarten
physics okay so here we have
kindergarten physics and what this file
didn't understand is that he says well
it's a thing it's a substance but it's
not uh not an object
well object is a synonym of thing is
saying the name of substance a synonym
of material watch more call it any of
those
they're all cinnamons synonyms perfect
synonyms for the purposes of physics
there's only objects and Concepts that's
it
and then on the other side you have that
which doesn't have shape and there you
see some synonyms nothing space
emptiness valid vacuum
okay so this is the first step you need
to undifferentiate nothing from
something and hopefully nothing in
something are antonyms and we can use
them consistently in any X position any
dissertation
okay so when he says let's it's it's not
a thing or it's uh it's not a uh an
object but it's a substance he's just
contradicting himself because he never
defined what an object is and as soon as
you bring that up he says oh you're
doing semantics Bill you're doing word
word salad word Wizardry
okay
so uh yeah we have to start at the
beginning and here are the foundations
that no one ever uh established for the
purposes of physics and actually for all
of science right and here it is uh these
are what we call the foundations what
all these people call semantics word
salad rubbish they have all these good
words for it right no one ever
discovered that you must Define the word
object in fact I keep saying that my
biggest contribution to science to
physics is not the the Rope model it's
having discovered the word object the
word thing no one in Ten Thousand Years
ever defined what a thing is
and I'll tell you partly why you know uh
part of the reason for that is that um
let me get this part of the reason for
that is that the word object the
physicist or research is in physics
natural philosophy whatever you want to
call it they delegated that job
to philosophers in fact the philosophers
took that word first because you go all
the way to the days of the Greeks and
they started doing you know a mixture of
philosophy and physics and then that
kind of branched out in the 17th century
and physicists or so-called physicists
the natural philosophers whatever they
were called they said hey you know uh
objects that's that's the job of
philosophers they have to Define that
English Majors uh you know people who
deal with semantics ontology all that
stuff and so here you have
a contradiction or a weird world where
you have the so-called philosophers
whatever they are because again we don't
have a definition for philosophy but
it's the philosophers the guys on the
other side of Campus who have to define
the bread and butter of the guys that
work in physics on the other side of
Campus
and the fellows you have to do physics
the people who have to explain how this
universe works they said oh you want to
know what an object is you got to go to
the other side of Campus
and so you go over there and you say
okay uh what do you guys do well we do
philosophy okay what do you do well we
study ontology and epistemology and
metaphysics and a whole bunch of
nonsense that we don't understand okay
and what is an object and you know we we
still haven't defined it
to this day they're still look at the
again the Stanford encyclopedia
philosophy or any any dictionary or uh
encyclopedia and you will not find a
definition a rational definition of the
word object of the word thing something
right that we can use in physics
and uh the physicists are not even aware
of it the mathematical physics they do
they we do equations
and you say what what are you doing
equations for well so that we can
explain how this universe works
and they try to give you an explanation
they give you an irrational explanation
you say but that's not an object and
they say oh but you're doing semantics
you want to know what an object is go to
the other side of campus and so you
never win it with them you know because
the people who have no stake in the word
object and the word thing are the ones
defining it for those who do have a
stake in the word thing because they
give you a they're going to give you a
physical interpretation they always do
because otherwise their math is
worthless and they're going to give you
a physical interpretation of their
equation we say it's irrational and they
say well yeah we don't understand it
either and father universe doesn't speak
our language and we don't speak his
language and they give you the runaround
when it's very simple they never Define
the word object that's the whole problem
okay so um uh that's one issue the other
one is that they never Define the word
exist no one ever defined a word exist
and it turns out that you can't do
physics without an object and physics is
a science of existence physics only
deals with uh with uh
the world that the world that exists out
there we're trying to figure out what
exists out there in the this invisible
world
and um
and yeah uh we're trying based on what
we think exists out there then we can
create mechanisms say look this is how
gravity works this is how light works or
electricity or magnetism we can because
now we've identified the invisible
intangible object that mother nature and
father Universe use
okay that's the way it works but if you
don't know what an object is well then
uh we got to start a little earlier and
none no one has ever defined the word
object can exist that's why they go
around in circles you know here you have
uh
you ask this question you know why do
atheists theists and agnostics go around
in circle when someone asks does God
exist
well I'll tell you why because they
never defined a word exist let alone God
but I mean if you don't know what the
word exists means what are you saying
when you say that God does not exist God
does exist you don't know whether God
exists I know God exists I believe God
exists what are you saying when you say
exist
and nobody ever defined a word exists
and that's why to this day they all go
around in circles with this famous word
so nobody knows what an object is nobody
knows what exists means and those are
the two first words you have to Define
in physics and that's why we have
irrational explanations today uh and the
question is who's doing word salad
is it uh people who try to Define these
terms and you know
etch them in stone or is it people who
avoid and say Ah that's just word
Wizardry
so that's what you got to think about
you know someone has to Define these
words and we can't use the words we
can't use tradition we can't use
Authority we can't use the dictionary
anymore now in other words in the
dictionary are property defined we have
to redefine them for the purposes of
Science of physics among them the
disciplines themselves so nobody has
defined these words that people think
that everything's been settled when
nothing absolutely nothing has been
settled nobody knows an object is nobody
knows what exists means nobody knows
what physic is about or what's physics
they're supposed to do they move energy
what do you mean you're moving energy
I thought and why are you talking about
matter if you're saying that uh
mathematical physics is just equations
and numbers what does matter have to do
with equations
so yeah when they talk about matter and
energy which is how they typically
Define
physics in terms of those two words you
say what does that have to do with math
which they say is the language of
physics and uh and they're saying no but
physics is matter
so what are you going to put in your
equation the word matter are you going
to put an atom there or what do you have
to put in there now you're going to put
a value and that's got nothing to do
with the definition you just gave for
physics
so there there's a contradiction between
what these people say is their job
description which is just doing
equations and how they Define physics
there's a there's a contradiction that's
never been resolved so don't tell me
everything's been settled and that we're
doing word Wizardry here
okay
um
here are some words that are at the
foundations of physics the ones on the
left are the ones we need in physics the
one on the right are the ones that the
mathematical establishment uh uses to
get their
theories across their their propaganda
really it's nothing more than propaganda
right so these are the terms that they
use over there on the right and a lot of
them are unscientific and irrational
in fact all of them are used in in the
wrong context
Etc because they talk about proof and
evidence and predictions and observation
none of which has anything at all to do
with science
now in science we do not observe we do
not gawk in science
we have to explain
science we do not study we do not make
predictions we're not astrologers okay
this is not a
predicting which horse is going to win
the race none of that we don't make
predictions in science we don't do
equations in science in in equations
it's only a description a math a
quantitative description of some
phenomena
that's not science that's like saying
that a chair has four legs and you put
the equation four legs plus one back
rest that's not science that's a
description
and science is not about describing it's
about explaining for that you need to
know the difference between an
explanation and a description and
knowing explanation is not a series of
descriptions
and again uh it takes two years for some
of these people to understand the
difference between an explanation and
the description first and therefore they
can't tell the difference between math
and science and math and physics okay so
this is this is where where the problems
are
okay and um so these are the foundations
the main words that we need to establish
the foundations of physics okay unless
you know these words you haven't gone
through kindergarten physics something
now which has shape nothing that which
doesn't have shade very very simple
right distance separation between two
objects location is the set of distances
you know from one object to all the
others that's the location of that
Adam that thing
with respect to all other matter in the
universe okay that's the location in the
universe no reference frames or anything
like that no observers we don't have
observers in science no one gawking
locations simply objectively defined
it's just the set of distances exist is
you know an object that has location
okay so if God wants to exist God not
only has to be an object God cannot be a
concept you cannot say God is love God
is intelligence no not in science that's
okay in the world of poetry that's okay
over there don't bring that into physics
in physics if God wants to exist first
he's got to be an object and you say
well God's a man he's got two arms two
eyes and ears no problem now he's an
object you point say that bearded guy
get over there that's God no problem
we're done you presented God now if God
wants to exist God has to have location
and the Rope model he's got to be part
of the
thread okay the single thread the
universal thread okay he's got to be
part of that dread uh he could be a
separate thread like you know we just
saw a separate thread we can say that
dread is God but then he has no
influence over us because this God has
no way of reaching us and we have no way
of reaching him you know he has no way
of touching seeing doing anything with
us because the only way you can see is
through the Rope the only way you can
hear is through atoms and none of his
atoms are connected to our atoms so we
can't hear them we can't see them we
can't do anything with God okay so as
far as we're concerned he doesn't exist
but uh he does exist in the sense that
he would be made of atoms that are
parallel to the single thread that makes
our universe in that sense you can say
God exists but it doesn't matter because
he has no way of contacting us so he
couldn't have created us either okay and
concept motion two or more location
concept a word that invokes or embodies
two objects two or two were treated as
objects so object is to one like concept
is to to
all right
that's the bottom line that's how we
start our um our
physics foundations that's those that's
how you start you know your
your presentation showing uh what an
object is what exists means now and what
a you know what you're proposing I'm
proposing the Rope okay so I hope we're
done right I hope he hopefully everybody
can follow my presentation doesn't mean
you believe it we don't care about
belief in science you can believe
whatever you want and here we're here
just so that you understand
what we're proposing once you understand
it you reach your own conclusion we
don't care doesn't concern science at
all
okay and then the other word uh that uh
these people were messing with is field
and boy I feel there's a problem so the
Klingon says what is real Sam
and yeah please point to it
and so yeah good old Sam's gotta you
know put his finger out there and uh and
point to the field right that's that's
the way it's done
so hopefully uh everybody can do it in
the same way I mean am I asking for
something out of the ordinary you say
that field is a thing you're going to
vibrate it you're going to move it
you're gonna say that the field moves a
charge whatever that is another number
you know 1.6 times 10 to the minus 19
coulombs okay just a number of value
okay so you have a field
and you're saying it's a physical object
you're saying it's a thing it's a
um
substance
oh it is really a region of numbers but
if you say that it's an object point to
it show me completely without anything
else in the in in you know near it it
can't be a dependent object it's got to
be a standalone option that's what a we
don't specify that because it's
understood
okay so uh here's uh one fellow and uh
he defines it as such he says in physics
field is just a quantity quantity what
is a quantity it's a number that is
represented by a tensor for all points
in space okay what is he saying he's
saying there's a region and it's got a
whole bunch of numbers which represent
uh some value you know what could be
temperature it could be gravity could be
magnetism strengths of certain certain
parameter that's all it is so if you
think of it in terms of say temperature
which is a scalar or your rank zero
tensor then you have all points in space
which have some value for temperature
and we could would call that temperature
field okay so we have a temperature
field okay so what is he talking about a
bunch of numbers in a region what are
those numbers they represent you know
the strengths or how hot something is or
whatever
we also have the electromagnetic field
which is a vector quantity and it has a
value for all points in space what is a
field a value for all points in space
please memorize that all of those people
who think it's a physical object no it's
not it's a region of values of
mathematical values it's got nothing to
do with physics or with science it's got
to do with measuring and saying the the
value here is such and the value there
is such that's all it is this is just an
abstract what concept
is field an object is it a thing no it's
an abstract concept that we use to
describe things not to explain but to
describe right and what are the lines of
force you know in the case of magnetism
lines of force are what not a thing they
don't exist okay there are useful
visualizations the tool and useful for
drawing diagrams or teaching
non-specialists about how the force
throughout a space kind of how it all
fits together
but really there are no such thing as
lines of force it turns out that it's
the other way around field is a concept
the line of force is a thing that's
moving inside the region people call
field okay and here we have the two
gurus Mr Faraday mixer Maxwell and they
have said it many times that people
never read them I cannot conceive curved
lines of force without the condition of
a physical existence in that
intermediate Space Mr Faraday said
and what is he saying he's saying the
those lines of fours are things those
are physical things that's the thing not
the field
and then we have uh Maxwell says feel
the space in the neighborhood of the
Electric magnetic bodies in that space
there is matter in Emotion matter in
motion
what is a line of force it's matter in
motion okay so for people to say that a
line of force is the concept and field
is the object they got it exactly in
reverse
okay
so they have it exactly in reverse the
line of force is what you have to
identify that's the thing that's the
that's the physical thing that's moving
in there
and what is the threats so under threads
we've got it done we we can tell you
what a what a line of force is it's a
thread that's moving inside there it's
moving right through the iron filings
and I showed that the other day how it
picks up all these iron foundings in
water you put the magnet in water it
picks up one at a time you can see it in
slow motion how all the iron filing
slowly gradually go towards the magnet
so why are they going towards the magnet
what's drawing them there well it's
because you have this skip rope you know
it's moving around at Great speeds and
picking up all these iron filings that
sense that skip wrote and pulling them
towards the magnet that's what it is so
the iron filings uh understand what a uh
what a line of force is uh humans don't
okay so here we have a field okay we
want to know what a field looks like
here I'll give it to you right there
okay Standalone field there's a field
with around a magnet now let's remove
the magnet is that what a field is
that's what a standalone field is a
bunch of arrows curved arrows
what are we staring at what are those
curved arrows if not lines of force
and people say you know there's no field
without a magnet well why
uh what what are we staring at what are
those lines of force
and this is the problem people never go
through there and uh and look at these
issues yeah the the lines of force are
real those are physical objects as Mr
Maxwell said it's matter in motion
and here you have uh the gravitational
field
yeah the gravitational field around the
earth the way they portray it and
there's the gravitational field without
the Earth
okay so what are those engine arrows we
see lots of engine arrows these days and
nobody explains what those engine arrows
are
you know why why what are what is that
field what is it made of what's moving
in there what's drawing you to the
Center of the Earth what's drawing an
astronaut to the center of the year or
the uh asteroids or the uh satellites
what's pulling on them
that's the question you got to answer
and you say what's the field well the
field is a concept you can't say the
field pulled them because the field is
just a region of values it just tells
you how strong the field is at that
point
so you can't use the word field in
science not to give an explanation
that's what science is about rational
explanation so the word feel has no
place in science
okay you got to tell me what physical
objects when when when you're pulling on
a donkey you know you tie a rope around
the donkey's neck and you're pulling on
the donkey everybody understands it you
don't need to go to college and learn
what the force is how much energy you
don't need to know about values you
don't need to know about mass or
anything like that you don't need
numbers or units you you ask a pygmy in
the in the middle of Africa you know
aborigine or whatever and say how do you
pull on a horse and he says well this is
the way I do it you tie a robe pull
did you go to college to learn that no
he just did it by practice he said this
is how you pull
okay and uh how do you produce pool
without an without an elongated object
and these people say it's the field
the lines of force that don't exist you
know no you can't pull on a horse unless
you put it and pull uh place a uh an
elongated object between your hands and
the horse's neck
then you can't you can't pull on
and people don't understand simple
simple things like that they they say no
no it's the force it's the energy it's
the mass you can't pull with mass you
can't pull with gravity because it's a
concept you can't say it the temperature
did it
you need a physical object you got to
put a stone you got to put a tree you
got to put a house a dog whatever
something between your hand and the and
the uh donkey to show how you pull on it
and the same thing with with us you know
if you're if you're falling down to
earth and you say well I jump and then
I'm being pulled downwards or I fall
downwards why do I fall down why don't I
keep just going to the Moon
something is drawing upon me something
is tugging me towards the Earth and you
say well there's nothing because I don't
see anything I can't touch anything well
you got the wrong definition of
something that's the first one you know
but then the question is you know if you
don't put something in there
then you're doing black magic you're
doing action at a distance you're doing
remote control you're doing what
witchcraft that's what you're doing
and um
this is more or less uh where is it
yeah here this more or less what it
looks like okay that's what you're doing
you're doing a bunch of Witchcraft when
you do that now you know you can go in
there and uh and use angels
you say well you know I don't believe in
angels well I don't care if you do this
guy has a theory and he says look I
think it's all done by Angels by Spirits
ghosts whatever
and so when they want to pull you know
they hold hands and they pull on each
other
and they're stuck to whatever object
there you are so the objects come
together and when the objects push each
other away you know they push they play
patty cake you know they push each other
away
no problem you understand the mechanism
oh but you say but I don't believe in
angels well
you don't have to believe in the theory
you just want to understand what the guy
what's going through the guy's head you
don't have to believe it he's just
trying to get you to understand what
what he's proposing
and people harp on belief and proof and
evidence when that's got nothing to do
with with science with physics he said
well well does putting angels in there
have to do with physics and science well
uh it's a little more rational
space-time or field
or mass or energy because at least the
guy's putting an object there and says
look this is the mechanism that I
proposed you don't have to believe in
angels you don't have to accept his
theory either but at least it's a little
more irrational than what you see out
there these people are putting Concepts
in there treating them as objects and
saying oh it's the field that pulled the
two objects together the gravitational
field or the magnetic field
what is that that's that's even worse
than uh black magic because now you're
putting a uh a concept and reifying it
turning it into a physical object
okay so yeah angels are superior to what
we see out there today
it doesn't mean you have to believe in
angels but uh give them a little more
credit than what we see out there today
okay
um
here we have
uh
moving on to the electricians okay uh
why do I call them electricians well
because these people in general you know
they've worked with equipment resistors
voltage amp meters Etc and so these
folks uh you know in general uh they are
against the establishment they they
don't like a lot of the theories out
there or they didn't like a lot of them
are dead now and so they proposed a
different world
but the question is whether what they
proposed is any more rational
than what's out there today uh
officially you know mathematical physics
and so these fellows you know they're
they're famous dissidents okay in
general okay some of them are live uh
most of them are dead
they've gone by in fact uh walthorne
Hill there
um he died I think in February of this
year
and I still have him as a friend in um
in Facebook
uh we became friends a long time ago in
Facebook uh we never talked I never had
a chat with him or anything never met
the guy uh but I have listened to a lot
of his uh speeches his uh dissertations
and so I know pretty much what he's
proposing at least in general terms you
know I'm I'm not interested in more
details if he doesn't make sense as it
is so uh you know he's he's talked about
a lot of stuff from the electric
universe and no under no circumstances
who I accept any of that stuff okay
again uh scientist is not a Critic
and we we're all dissidents in that
sense we criticized The Establishment no
problem but then the question is you
know under what
um arguments are you criticizing The
Establishment that's one issue and the
other one is what do you propose in
exchange which is really more important
you know a scientist is not the critic
who's in the stands watching the fight
the scientist is the guy who's boxing
so the guy the critic says oh you should
have hit him with a left hand and
yeah yeah why don't you get up there
okay yeah scientists the guy who fights
the guy who proposes the guy who's you
know in the thick of things not not the
guy who's out there criticizing so
criticizing is no problem you know it's
great but again
um the issue there also is that if you
have a
irrational argument that even your
criticism is worthless
so not only does your criticism have to
be rational that's one issue but then
you have to propose something in
exchange something rational that is
scientific you got to propose a
mechanism how does this universe work
if you can't answer that question you're
not a scientist you're not a physicist
yeah
okay so um
here we have um
this is what they do a lot of people do
of these uh electricity and electricians
they deal with a oscilloscopes and uh
um both meters and amp meters and so on
they like to measure things and in that
sense they're quite in a sense like the
establishment and it is because these
people emphasize all this um all the
stuff that other experience in the lab
that they uh think that they have enough
uh arguments to debunk The Establishment
okay so that's more or less what's going
through their heads and and these people
love gadgets especially electronic
gadgets and here a couple of examples
I'm going to put these up here so that
you can see what these people are into
you know they move these magnets around
they uh look at the lines that they make
okay at the uh what lines of force okay
and uh here's a here's another one let
me show you this one
okay and they move these uh
magnets around they show you how it
affects the magnetic field or the lines
of force they play around with all this
stuff
and they love it and this is what they
put on the internet and they put on the
YouTube you know so they take up a lot
of space with showing you a lot of these
things a lot of them are just for
selling products some of them are just
to show you something neat
and um and here you have another one let
me show you this one okay these are
little gadgets that all these people
love and this is what these people are a
lot about you know here you see what
this fellow does with this
he built this uh little track
and moves around
and he shows how the
magnets keep this thing rolling around
forever
okay
great
levitron or whatever they call it here's
another one final one
okay
they love all these gadgets okay
so what's the problem with all this well
the problem with all this is that not a
one person explains how that magic is
done the magic you're observing there
okay and uh and this is the issue how
how did the how does Mother Nature do
this uh these magic these magic tricks
and they never explain it they just show
it I've done science you know I've shown
a magic trick and it's a wondrous chick
trick that you cannot explain
well can you explain it the guy who
showed it and of course they can't and
so what's the purpose of taking up you
know space on the internet showing all
these things getting lots of hits
you know and not explaining the trick
how do you do that trick you know a
magician can do a trick and if you press
them hard enough maybe if you torture
him you know waterboard him or whatever
uh maybe he'll tell you how the trick is
done
well I would like to waterboard some of
these people to see if they could tell
me you know how the trick is done do you
think they would be able to
and the answer is no they have no idea
how that trick is done they just want to
show you how fancy how great it is and
this is this is the problem a lot of
these people take up the airwaves with
nonsense and none of them explain it and
that's part of the problem that we see
with these electrical electric Universe
folk and uh people like Ken wheeler and
so on they don't explain nothing they
have no idea how any of this stuff works
they just invent words uh they use they
move Concepts around they don't even
realize it
okay so here's a
H this is how the electricians in
general you know some of those people I
just mentioned uh why they don't like
relativity and I guess the main problem
is time they don't like special
relativity and they don't like general
relativity they don't like time dilation
life contraction Mass increase they
don't agree with any of that stuff in
general you know something there you've
got all kinds of dissidents out there
right uh they reject general relativity
you know space-time workspace black
holes dark matter they reject all that
stuff nuclear sun no the sun doesn't uh
according to them is not powered by
nuclear fusion process wormholes
Multiverse and all that stuff they
reject it completely okay
um black hole Dark Matter Etc they say
those are all electromagnetic causes
okay uh big bang they say it never
happened
but then they propose you know some
nonsense but uh Tracy etched the
mountains of in channels of Mars and our
wiser forefathers documented these
events so they bring all this mythology
at least the electric Universe does
right and they say that you know all our
forefathers were so intelligent we lost
all that knowledge
okay they probably saw ETS you know the
ones who built the pyramids you know
okay
um gravity electromagnetic causes again
and a great part of the reason for that
is they believe that it's the same
equation Newton's equation matches you
know the electromagnetic equation where
you have a constant times charge charge
divided by distance Square well that
pretty much resembles you know the
gravitational constant G Mass 1 Mass 2
divided by distance Square so it looks
like uh gravity is really an
electromagnetic phenomena
and the problem there is they don't know
what electromagnetic is they don't know
what electricity is they don't know
magnetism is but they just want to do it
through equations okay and then so all
that you can offer is irrational
rejoinders you know for everything that
the establishment has and so people say
well Bill why don't you join them you're
all Against The Establishment you're all
you're all dissonant you're you're all
fighting mathematical physics yeah but
uh we don't agree on hardly anything
even in the arguments that we raise
Against The Establishment so the fact
that we all criticize The Establishment
does not put me in the same boat as they
do as they're in okay I'm in a different
boat altogether okay I have a totally
different uh proposal for How the
Universe works and therefore my
arguments against the establishment are
completely different than anybody else
out there you know can we either uh uh
the uh what is it the um
John Chappelle society which a lot of
them deal with ether uh the electric
Universe all these groups out there and
others that maybe I don't even know
about they they criticize it on the
wrong foundations on the wrong basis why
because they're proposing exactly the
same thing as the establishment what is
the problem well here uh hopefully I can
synthesize it for you here okay this is
more or less why I'm not in the same
boat as they are you know uh the
electricians they have the same notion
of Science and the scientific method
than the establishment they learned it
at the same schools at the same
monasteries okay they all went to the
same High School the same colleges and
so they come up with the same notion of
Science and we're saying that the
science that day all these people do
that we've been doing for the last 400
years has nothing at all to do with
science so we we rejected completely uh
the harp on experiments prediction
observation evidence proof and math we
reject all those every single one of us
none of those have anything to do with
science science is not about running
experiments because experiments are only
used to persuade people to to produce
evidence essentially right and then to
try to convince people that's not what
we do in science in science we present
and a mechanism in the case of physics
right we present a mechanisms
objectively so that person understands
the mechanism the causes and then we're
done that's the end of science what
continues is belief you know whether you
believe it or not and that's personal
and it's got nothing to do with science
so we do not convince we do not persuade
in science what we do we do that we're
all human so we tend to do that but
that's not the point of science that
part is the religion part of the
dissertation the the strictly scientific
part is just objective mechanism that's
what it is uh they use the same language
they pair with the same language all
these people you know they have the same
uh exact words that they learned from
the same people okay the the the the
people they criticize right so the
electricians they criticize the
mathematical establishment but then they
use the same words and then you see some
of them plasma ether field wave charge
Vortex they love birkeland currents
electricity you know these are their
words but they also use a whole bunch of
uh words that um
that the mathematical establishment uses
you know like mass and uh
um well field there you see force and so
on and all those words none of those
words belong in physics none of those
words they're all Concepts we do not
move Concepts plasma is a concept ether
is a concept field is a concept wave is
a concept and so on down the line all
those are Concepts electricity is a
concept it's not a physical object
okay and it takes 10 years for these
people to understand that okay
electricity is not a physical object and
people say well stick your fingers in uh
in the outlet and find out if it gives
you a kick well yeah again it's not seat
touch it's not the criteria for
determining objects okay you don't know
what you touched oh you know you got a
shot you don't know even why okay
anyways
um they invoke the same uh quantum
mechanical structural models you know
the atom the electron proton they have
the planetary model so ionization they
explain it in the same way you know the
electron bead flies away electricity is
uh flowing beads you know around the
wire they talk about positive and
negative you know when attracting the
other positive rejects positive negative
rejects negative and so on uh and they
typically have attraction via pressure
why because they know that they can they
don't have an elongated object between
any the two test objects so they have to
produce it through pressure because they
can never have produced a force of pull
they never invented the force of pull in
mathematical physics we do not have the
force of pull for the last ten thousand
years nobody can explain the force of
pull because in order to do so you need
an elongated object that mediates
between two objects and that's why we
don't have the force of people today
anywhere in mathematical physics or in
the dissident world
the definitions you know they reject
them as semantics and word salad and
ontology and all that they say no that's
philosophy how do you come here to do
philosophy I came here to do physician
you know uh field uh they say the field
is an object and it exists whereas the
lines of force they don't exist they're
just uh tools for visualization
okay so this is the problem the problem
is that uh the math the critics use the
same language essentially as the
establishment they have the same concept
they use the same atom and we reject all
of that we have a different atom we have
a different uh mediator for light yeah
here it is looks like this looks like a
rope nobody has ever proposed that on
planet Earth okay so we have a totally
different uh Theory hypothesis and
theory we have two of the different
assumptions about how the universe is
and how it works and so we're not in the
same boat as all these electricians
we're completely different than them and
we also criticize The Establishment on
from a different angle we don't use the
same words that these people do these
people try to prove that the
establishment is wrong we do not prove
we say they're irrational because we
Define these words and we say that under
rationality you people are not part of
science you don't belong in science at
all completely out because all your all
your language is irrational Therefore
your theories are irrational and your
vision of how this universe is you know
what exists out there and how it works
is completely you know bogus
so so we're not in the same boat as all
these dissidents we don't care if we're
all criticizing The Establishment we're
not on the same boat with them okay
they're totally different people
okay
um here we have some examples
let's see if I can get this thing up
there okay this is uh well Thornton and
like I said he died a couple months ago
and uh and not a bad guy but he was
completely mistaken about how this
universe works he was not a physicist he
was a metaphysical uh if you can call
him that not even that because
um you know he he tried to engage like
so many other people like Ayn Rand for
example and so many others who dealt
with
um with physics without knowing and what
does he say well here's just an example
okay he says Uh there's the speed of
light okay depends on the medium and of
course we know that light slows down
when it goes through air and water if
the density of the medium of space
changes then the speed of light will
vary
okay uh absolutely wrong okay he's got
that completely wrong light always
travels at the same speed between any
two atoms irrespective of the medium uh
it doesn't matter where the atom is in
the universe light travels always at the
same speed between any two atoms why
because it's torsion along a rope and
that's why the wave equation C equals
frequency times wavelength is a constant
because only a rope can imitate that
equation that's why the wave equation is
the equation of a rope and nothing but a
rope there can't be any other thing that
can imitate
that wave equation certainly not
particles certainly not one-way waves
you know which are actually not waves
which are what are these ways there are
vectors traveling vectors gravity
numbers magnitude and directions that's
what it is
and then you have the American Museum of
Natural History and they say more or
less the following says no matter how
you how you measure it the speed of
light is always the same which kind of
contradicts with uh Thornhill said here
okay light from a moving Source has the
same velocity as light from a stationary
Source in other words what they're
bringing up they're saying look you
don't add the speed of light to the
moving object like you would like you
know uh you're on the train you throw
the ball the ball you have to add the
speed in which the train also is
traveling so you add the speed of the
train to the speed of the ball you can't
do that with light travel will light
will travel at the same speed
irrespective of how fast the train
travels okay and that's what they're
saying there although it might seem
logical to add the speed of the light
source and the speed of the light beam
to determine the total speed of light
to the total speed uh light does not
work in that way okay the speed of light
is constant and does not depend on the
speed of the light source well we have a
problem because when fellow Theory says
the speed of light changes depending on
the medium it goes through these other
fellows are saying the speed of light is
never added to the speed of the source
and they're talking about two different
things yeah but uh both of them are
wrong you know because
um well I'm sorry the uh the Natural
Museum is not wrong it's just that they
don't know why they cannot answer why
that's the case they're just making a
statement they're just saying it is so
but they haven't told you why it's so
and neither could Einstein or pankare
and any uh Lawrence or any of these
people they could not tell you why why
can't they tell you why because they
never identify the mediator of Light
which is a rule with a rope yeah you can
see why okay
um you know
um you don't add the speed of uh of
light to the speed of the source because
what you have is the atom is sliding to
the Rope
so you have the atom is uh pumping and
torquing the rope and as it moves
through the Rope it eats into the Rope
so it doesn't push the Rope which is
what's happening when you throw the ball
from the train from the speeding train
you're in the front of the train you
throw the ball the ball goes fast and
you have to add the speed of the ball to
the speed of the train you can't do that
with light because you're sliding
through the rope and eating into it as
the Rope you know uh forms the electron
shell and the proton and then continues
out the back so you're kind of sliding
to it that's why the speed of light is
not added to the speed of the source of
the atom that's moving and so we can
answer all these questions now
qualitatively okay you don't have to
agree you don't have to believe we can
answer it and we have an explanation you
don't like the explanation tell us
what's wrong with the explanation
okay that's what you got to do and these
people don't even answer why and they
can't because you can't simulate what I
just said with little particles with
little balls which is how they talk
about when they talk about light they
talk about photons and then they just in
case they say well photon is also a wave
okay use a wave I don't care use
particles or waves whichever one you
wish to use explain with a wave why does
the wave not accelerate when it's coming
out of an atom that's accelerating
because the waves the electromagnetic
waves are
emitted by an atom and atom pumps those
are the official version atom pumps
right we have this uh
um planetary model and so you have this
little b that goes back and forth when
it falls and when it comes out what it
does is absorbs and emits radiation
energy
waves right electromagnetic waves so the
wave goes out so why don't you add that
wave which is going one way to the speed
of the atom that which is going in the
same direction you should
but they're saying you don't and they're
not explaining why you don't what's the
physical reason what's what's the cause
okay
and this is where the problem is they
they don't tell you why and so while
Thornhill was wrong first of all because
um
uh Adam's always I'm sorry light always
travels at the same speed between any
two atoms and here you see an example
and it's the prism famous prison that
they show and whether you use particles
or waves
you know why does the um uh
why does the beam of Light which comes
in as a baby white light why does it
break up into all these different colors
coming out of the prism
and obviously if they come out of the uh
prism we have two problems the first one
is if they go slower through the prism
what accelerates them once they come out
of the prism again
why do they always travel 300 000
kilometers on both sides of the prism
and slower within the prism in other
words what accelerates and once they
leave the prism
that's the question okay that's one
issue the other issue is why do we have
colors if colors are different
frequencies different wavelengths that's
all it is and the question is why why do
we have
um red versus blue coming out why
doesn't white light come out
what breaks it up
okay and so you cannot explain these two
questions you cannot really answer them
with the wave or the particle model but
with a rope model it's a cinch okay
there you have it you have the Rope
coming in and you have a rope tied to
another atom and we're just going to
assume that there's only two atoms there
right the White and the red the White
and the yellow the White and the blue
and when it goes to the blue the blue is
a higher frequency meaning the shorter
links and the red is longer links and
fewer links or in other words frequency
is lower and
the wavelength or length length as we
call it is longer that's what we have
there so it's very easy to understand
why because you can see that the
distance changes from one to the other
so we're done it's very easy does light
travel differently in any of those no
light is the same speed between any two
atoms between the White and the red it's
300 000 kilometers per second and
between the red and whatever comes out
you know at the other end another atom
that would be over there also 300 000
kilometers per second there's no
speeding up of light after it comes out
of the prism and that's what these
people cannot explain see here why does
light go uh at 300 000 kilometers
inwards towards the magnet from left to
right right go slower throughout the
prism and then when it comes out it goes
back to 300 000 kilometers per second
how does it do that what speeds it up
what is it that makes light go faster
when it comes out of the prism
you know how why does it accelerate and
here you can see there is no
acceleration it's just always travels at
the same speed between any two atoms
what changes is only the frequency
versus wavelength which is the uh
equation of a rope and the equation in
the uh also the wave so-called wave
equation
okay so we have an explanation for all
these phenomena which The Establishment
does not and it's a physical
interpretation which they can't give you
they say well we don't understand that
the father Universe speaks a different
language we don't understand and we'll
never figure it out we're studying
someday we'll figure it out you know no
they never will because they're not even
researching these qualitative questions
they're just doing equations that's all
they do
okay so here we have another fellow his
name is Ken wheeler and he's a colorful
guy you know he's uh
he uh you know he has his own little
show there and I have no problem you
know with his personality that's that's
great he could be any way he wants that
that doesn't affect me at all it affects
a lot of people out there but to me it
doesn't affect me at all he can be
arrogant he can be uh you know cussing
people out no problem the question is
what is the bottom line Ken I mean what
is this fellow proposing what does he
what how does he think the universe
works that's that's the bottom line
that's what we want to understand
and he goes in there and this is out of
his video there is the engine of
magnetism you can look him up if you
understand magnetism fully as the flip
side of the coin of die electricity you
understand both you really can
understand 95 of nature okay great great
statement great beginning let's see how
much we understand
centrifugal uh Divergence centripetal
convergence is the fight between the
magnetic and the dielectric okay
whatever you said there okay charge this
chart centrifugal uh centripetal uh
spatial or counter spatial okay when
we're talking about something spatial
we're talking about the release of
energy I wonder where he got that word
energy maybe he invented it the release
of force I wonder where you got that
word Force the creation of the toroidal
field of magnetism field I wonder where
you get these words energy force and
field that's where he's going to be
moving he's going to be kicking the
energy and uh you know throwing the
field and moving the uh Force
increasing inertia and acceleration
towards its greater energy in other
words the inverse of the dissipation of
energy and yeah you can listen to him
all day and you won't understand squat
because he doesn't understand what he's
saying and again it's not about his
personality it's got to do with what
he's what's coming out of his mouth
which is nonsense and
um his videos are a lot better than this
book I mean I I started reading his book
and I read almost halfway I don't think
I met it halfway but close to halfway
and I've never read a book like that you
don't understand you cannot possibly
understand what you wrote it's just all
Goblin it's not you cannot
understand any paragraph you don't know
what he's saying
he's talking there he's just blabbing
throwing out words
and it's worse than I thought I thought
the book would be a lot better than uh
what he has on his show you know he's
got a a YouTube site and he uh he talks
a lot of nonsense on the on the waves
but I said well his book he's got more
time to think about it you know he's
going to be writing it
no it's even worse the book his writing
is worth in his talking he talks better
in his he writes and it's all
gobbledygook it's just nonsense
everything that comes out of his mouth
so all these dissidents the fact that
you know he criticizes The Establishment
okay fine he says look you know
space-time is garbage Dark Matter dark
uh black holes no problem
but what is his argument and that's when
you look at his arguments you say no
this guy's talking nonsense that's all
coming out of his mouth so the fact that
he criticizes the establish and does not
put me in the same boat as him or wal
Thornhill or any of these people you
know their criticism is nonsense and
what they propose is even bigger
nonsense than the establishment in great
measure because they use the same
language as the establishment
and as long as they move Concepts around
they're going to be just as irrational
or even worse than the establishment so
you know all I can tell you is
no no we're not in the same boat with
any of these people the electricians
they have a different world a different
universe but everything they propose is
just garbage nonsense
uh that's the best thing I could say for
them so don't don't confuse me with any
of them we'll see you next week bye bye